laisser sa voiture se garer toute seule
ou l'appeler à la sortie d'un restaurant
pour qu'elle vienne vous chercher
vous en rêviez c'est aujourd'hui
possible des prototypes de véhicules
automatiques étaient présentés au public
à versailles vendredi dernier à
l'origine quatre entreprises yvelinoise
plein d'idées qui ont remporté l'appel à
projets du conseil général véhicules
intelligents ville du futur
mais une voiture intelligente c'est quoi
exactement petite démonstration en
images mohamed conduit son véhicule à
l'entrée du parking
grâce à cette borne l'automobile se met
en mode automatique et repère quelle
place est libre maintenant levé que
converse en automatique en suivant les
lignes au sol
autre exemple avec le projet taxi colle
une navette hybride qui peut fonctionner
en mode automatique ou avec un
conducteur particularité un chauffeur
peut conduire un convoi de cinq
véhicules relié à ses côtés le projet
1001 autres véhicules hybrides destinés
au transport de marchandises dans des
lieux dédiés comme les hangars un
système d'auto partage permet de
répartir la flotte selon les besoins
sans intervention humaine et enfin
quatrième et dernier projet la ligne
kengo une voiture électrique futuriste
un volant qu'on imaginerait plutôt dans
un avion et de multiples innovations
high-tech une interface homme-machine
que peut avoir ici qu'il est tactile
mais ensuite en mode autonome c'est
cette fait l'intérêt de la voiture c'est
que la voiture la banquette se retourne
et 180 et on a finalement
l'environnement le conducteur peut
totalement participer à la convivialité
de la voiture en créant cet espace sur
sa cour du coeur et passagers se font
face et peuvent sur cet écran géant
visualiser la route
regarder un film ou encore aller sur les
réseaux sociaux comme les autres
véhicules elle se gare toute seule et un
bras automatique la branche à une borne
de recharge
rassemblés sous la bannière du conseil
général ces quatre véhicules du futur
ont bénéficié d'un sérieux coup de pouce
ce sont des entreprises installées dans
les yvelines c'est bien entendu la
condition sinequanone et notre aide a
été atteint le niveau de 3 millions
d'euros pour ces pour ces entreprises et
on leur a porté outre l'argent une
reconnaissance à travers la présence
d'un stand du conseil général des
yvelines au salon de genève qui en
termes de calendrier le premier grand
salon international
chaque année dans le contexte actuel
assez véhicule n'aurait peut-être pas vu
le jour
les yvelines reste aujourd'hui le
premier département automobile
le secteur emploie quarante cinq mille
personnes